I must give the British people a very
simple instruction you must stay at home
to slow the spread of the disease
never in peacetime have we seen anything
like it this is the story of Britain's
first two weeks living in lockdown seen
through the eyes of those living through
it it's gonna like knock-on into the
next couple of years and some agonizing
decisions along the way if I don't go
then I won't receive this treatment that
so far has been prolonging my my life
millions of people are now left
wondering how long this will last
so we're just having a staff meeting
over zoom this is our year 16 so my name
is Hooda alia slam head teacher lady for
primary school my makeshift office in
the front shoe my mother is 80 years old
and it's been really really difficult
not seeing her during this time she has
many underlying conditions and all her
grandchildren are desperate to see her
it's Mary miss you too give me a big
smile I also have a daughter who is
currently in her seventh month of
pregnancy and we've had to isolate her
from all of us because we were still
coming to school and that's been
difficult as well just going out for my
daily bit of exercise when the lockdown
begins it comes as a bit of a relief to
hood her that week was probably one of
the most stressful weeks of my career
because I felt very responsible for the
community that you know our school
serves I could see the anxiety in
people's faces they wanted me to have
all of the answers and I didn't have the
answers
[Music]
Matt and granya have been self isolating
in their small house in Liverpool with
five-year-old michael two-year-old Noah
and baby surin Matt's a musician but
work has dried up since the lockdown and
money is tight and the kids are bored
well we don't have a lot of space you
just got a little tiny little yards or
yards and this is our little square
outside the house is our street here
it's usually full of kids playing all
day long it's really quiet
hey Mikey and for young Michael the curb
is now his classroom
he calls it cool school I discussed what
school squeals tell me one of those Matt
is desperate for an income and his only
hope now rests on the government who've
said they'll help out self-employed
workers who can provide accounts for the
last three years toys of their conscious
socialism said come on give us a hand
with this guy it's like it's like
watching their house and meet a Labour
Chancellor just very surreal
so we've got a little makeshift office
set up Scott and Laura are both
self-employed Laura's a wedding florist
and Scott's a plasterer their work has
ground to a sudden halt
but the pillows are coming thick and
fast no work from now until basically
the end of June when you speak to them
they say there's a pandemic you look at
your actual contract there's nothing in
there it's about 50,000 pounds in work
just gone this is where it really starts
and that things really start to hit the
fan it's gonna have a really negative
effect and it's gonna like knock-on into
the next couple of years for some living
in lockdown the restrictions can mean
the difference between life and death
this is Heather in 2016 she was
diagnosed with incurable lung cancer but
since then she's been receiving
revolutionary treatment which is keeping
her alive but that treatment is in
London the epicenter of the pandemic in
the UK if she travels she's being told
she may not be allowed back on the
island if I don't go then I won't
receive this treatment that so far has
been prolonging my my life ad if I do go
and catch the virus well you know who
might be gone fairly shortly anyway it's
really difficult it's quite a quite a
worrying time but can only hope for the
best and get to travel hopefully hi my
name is his Sina slack and it's Sunday
the 28th Haseena lives with her husband
Harry and 16 month old Sophie on on the
outskirts of Nottingham to be fair Harry
used to bake well before coronavirus had
kicked off but it's definitely come in
handy now so Harry's mum has just done a
shop for us this will last us for a good
week and she's been really kind
just because we're self isolating at the
moment so we've just finished having our
lunch
Haseena is pregnant and she's also a key
worker in her community she decides to
continue work which means leaving the
house well normally used to take me an
hour takes me about 15 20 minutes tops
now to get to work and so in some ways
it's a good thing people who listen
about the social distancing and this
also splittin about staying home
so this is our parish center and
normally every day that week this place
would be absolutely buzzing with people
and a whole host of other things take
place in this building as well or
throughout the year and as you can see
it's just completely empty at the moment
the only person using this building is
me because I've got to you for the
office I felt safe strange not being
able to have the power of human touch at
this time I mean normally as you go
about your day to day life you you have
a natural thing for me is that quite a
tactile person would be to shake hands
with people and to shake hands with
people that you need to to hug those we
love from those who we work among than
those who reserve and it felt so strange
so obscure not to be able to do any of
that
the government's lockdown has seen
schools closed and children sent home so
we're taking out a box one busting at
lady pulled primary school head teacher
Hooda has reopened the doors so that
some families can collect food parcels
and then when the parents come they can
collect it and keep a safe distance from
us at the same time this is the new life
in the lockdown yes lockdown for them
I'm sure is very difficult
some of the families live in very small
houses so the work that we're sending
home is going to be difficult for some
of those parents to support their
children within their households are you
worried about them
absolutely absolutely I miss my children
a lot and I'm checking that they're
doing the homework every day I am
calling them at home to make sure that
they're okay I'm just worried that
they're going to miss so much school but
I know they need to keep safe our school
is always buzzing with excitement
giggles joy laughter it's not meant to
be a deserted building
the UK has experienced a big jump in the
number of people who've died from
coronaviruses now stands at one thousand
four hundred and fifty two thousand
three hundred and fifty two people have
now died look at worse before they get
better that's the message from the Prime
Minister in a letter being sent to 30
even though the news is getting worse
communities are just and millions find a
way to say thank you to those on the
front line so I've just had my shift at
work just to make sure that I am keeping
clean and making sure I wash my hands
regularly when we talking stuff in just
yet so can we get washed up and then
hopefully how are you yeah are you doing
today's topic was really about Boris
Johnson sending out letters to say it's
gonna get worse before it's gonna get
better so that was a bit of a weird
feeling I guess it went but great to
hear so yes so it's given me some time
to think today as to really what this is
meant for us
right so I'm just going through my
direct debits to see what we can and
can't sort still no wiser whether I
qualify for any of the help for
self-employed people most of the people
that I speak to that self-employed
they're in this thing boat they don't
think it applies to them they're not
sure everyone's under the impression
it's not their fault which it isn't so
what the hell did we do
visiting my own granddaughter from a
window is just as difficult and I'm
looking at her through FaceTime how
quick she's growing she's one years old
now and and every time I her mom sends
us a video she's she's passed another
milestone and we're missing all of that
and that's really really difficult for
me as a priest one of the greatest
casualties of witnessed over these past
two weeks has been those who are
grieving normally when you go to visit a
family who would believe do you go to
their home you shake their hands you sit
down in the living rooms you listen as
stories are told of the person who they
lost so much you pray for them in person
then you make them the promise that
together you'll meet the service as
fitting a goodbye as possible as perfect
as possible
and actually I can't make that promise
right now I can't make the promise that
the service will be as perfect as
possible because it won't you having to
tell grieving families that they can't
have flowers that they can't have more
than ten people at the service that they
can't have the service in a church the
some relatives perhaps shouldn't be
present because they're high-risk when
you look around and there's key people
missing they're at the graveside and
we're just witnessing families fall
apart we're just witnessing immeasurable
heartache and whilst we can make the
promise that in three months time in six
months time whenever the time comes that
we'll have a memorial service that will
say goodbye to their loved one in the
way that at any other points they could
have done it's hard to escape the
reality of how much this is delay in
people's grief and for some families
they're just never going to want to open
up those wounds
[Music]
ladies and gentlemen refilling the air
traffic in the Isle of Man Heather
Christian has made the decision to
travel to London for vital cancer
treatment
the journey takes her to the heart of
the UK's epidemic
Heather's treatment goes ahead as
planned and she's allowed to return home
the same day Britain may look very
different right now but there are
glimmers of hope amid the uncertainty so
managed to move all my wedding bookings
apart from one and we took advantage of
the free legal advice that we've got
with our insurance which was the best
thing we've ever done because it I think
that was a solicitor and it managed to
get like any threat of legal action sort
of straight away so that's all done with
us one stress off my mind who would have
thought 2020 would have turned out to be
such a year and but I guess the if
anything it's shown how we come together
as a community and how Britain is
working together to get through this
when this is over I think the legacy of
this whole coronavirus will be how we
all came together as a community
lockdown is keeping us apart from each
other and it is creating some distance
but it's not going to break up our
community it's only I think making us
stronger
you